america and its allies are announcing
new sanctions against russia today
that's after ukrainian president
vlodimir zielinski made an impassioned
plea to the u.n yet another to do more
to stop the russians including a
possible war crimes tribunal like the
nuremberg trials that brought former
nazi leaders to justice after world war
ii nancy cordes has more from the white
house
they killed entire families adults and
children and anguished vladimir zelinski
just back from bucha accused russian
troops of gunning down hundreds of
defenseless ukrainian civilians for
pleasure
show all the other potential war
criminals in the world how they will be
punished
an independent tribunal is one option
under consideration now that leaders
from several european nations have
accused russia of committing war crimes
what we've seen in mbucha is not
the random act of a rogue unit
it's a deliberate campaign
to kill
to torture
to rape
to commit
atrocities
and u.s officials warn the atrocities
are still ongoing reports indicate that
russian federal security agents are
confiscating passports
and ids
taking away cell phones and separating
families from one another
i do not need to spell out what these
so-called filtration camps are
reminiscent of
susanna sakoto is the director of the
war crimes research office at american
university which atrocities that we've
seen in ukraine would likely be
considered war crimes indiscriminate
attacks and attacks deliberately
targeting civilians we've seen russian
forces destroying apartment buildings
schools hospitals including a maternity
hospital
infrastructure civilian vehicles
shopping centers a theater
ambulances
so there's there's many
war crimes and yet russian leaders still
deny targeting civilians in bucha or
anywhere else
among the new sanctions that president
biden is expected to announce today are
new restrictions on investments in
russia and there are reports gail that
vladimir putin's own adult daughters
could be financially targeted
nancy thank you very much